thank you Brian this is a rock turbulent
rock tuna from Istanbul Turkey your
question indeed is an interesting one it
is an enormous potential that I see in
Latin America we do youth and I was
watching this morning from Cabana hotel
in the beach they were playing football
with it early hours and a lot of the
answers are in sports and there's a lot
of energy and that energy this could be
the driving force movement in america
latin america is rich with a lot of
minerals and natural reserves are major
major major as if this country has but
that has to be channeled through with
the right fashion the future for latin
america for the drone is a huge can
invest people to the young and the
mormon is a vesicle education of the
young and that the more the young people
will be dedicated to tap those resources
effectively i think all the investment
should really be focused on the young
people muscularly on education fun